what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things
marvel cinematic universe and today we
have some great news to start your
weekend off the right way
spider-man 3 has officially begun
filming
with the main cast tom holland is on set
filming as we speak right now we have an
actual set photo shared by tom holland
himself and that means
spoilers are going to be coming very
soon and speaking of spoilers it seems
like we may have actually learned the
title of the movie
the website for production weekly
currently lists spider-man 3 and they
list it right now as
spider-man homesick now as far as a
title is concerned it's not a bad title
especially since we pretty much know at
this point thanks to this photo today
that spider-man is going to be on the
run
and probably is not going to be able to
come home because he's going to be a
wanted fugitive for the murder of
mysterio and we know this because if we
take a look at the photo that tom
holland shared today on instagram we
actually learned a little bit about the
movie
he posted this a couple hours ago with
the title wear a mask
i'm wearing too and if we look at him we
can see that this
is the exact same spider-man suit that
we saw at the very end of spider-man
fire from home and this is a new photo
of him
in the suit which means spider-man 3
spider-man homesick whatever we're
calling it right now is going to pick up
immediately after spider-man far from
home which isn't that big of a surprise
but this pretty much confirms it
so the last time we left peter parker in
spider-man far from home his identity
was revealed and now everybody knows
that he's spider-man
mysterio also framed him for his murder
and all of the attacks on the people as
well
and the last thing that spider-man said
was what the and then it ended so that's
where we left off and that's where we're
going to pick up from
immediately in fact i wouldn't be
surprised if the opening scene was
actually just a replay of the
post-credits scene where peter parker's
identity is revealed
then from there we'll see him go on the
run and he'll have to leave home so
homesick may indeed
be the title but we'll have to wait and
see it should be revealed pretty soon
since they are officially
filming now so let me know how excited
you are and let me know what you think
about the possible title of spider-man
homesick be sure to let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest
spider-man
mcu news for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof